thank you
affairs
uh
there's nowhere
okay
thanks mikey
oh
uh
good afternoon or is it still morning
nope after
still morning feels like a long day hi
everyone my name is ariel bradford i'm
the spokesperson for the civil rights
division
this serves as your two minute warning
um today we will have
our speakers be attorney general merrick
garland and assistant attorney general
kristen clarke
they will be joined on stage by deputy
attorney general lisa monaco
as well as associate attorney general
vanita gupta
following assistant attorney general
clark's remarks
we will be happy to take a couple of
questions from everyone on stage
thank you
um
yes
thank you
good morning i'm pleased to be joined by
deputy attorney general lisa monaco
associate attorney general vinita gupta
and assistant attorney general for civil
rights kristin clark
i want to begin today though by
expressing my condolences
for the community in surfside florida i
know how difficult it is
for the families who have lost and for
those who are waiting to hear
and i express great gratitude for the
first responders
and for the others who are assisting in
the ongoing rescue operation
i know that the federal government is
providing assistance
to the state and local governments and
we stand ready
as things develop to provide more
assistance
if it is required
the rights of all eligible citizens to
vote
are the central pillars of our democracy
they are the rights from which all other
rights
ultimately flow two weeks ago i spoke
about our country's history of expanding
the right to vote
i noted that our progress on protecting
voting rights
especially for black americans and
people of color
has never been steady moments of voting
rights expansion
have often been met with counter efforts
to curb the franchise among other things
i expressed concern about the dramatic
rise in state legislative actions that
will make it harder
for millions of citizens to cast a vote
that counts
i explained that the justice department
is rededicating its resources to
enforcing federal law
and to protecting the franchise for all
eligible voters
and i promised that we are scrutinizing
new laws
that seek to curb voter access and that
where we see
violations of federal law we will act
in keeping that promise today the
department of justice
is suing the state of georgia our
complaint alleges that recent changes to
georgia's election laws
were enacted with the purpose of denying
or abridging the right of black
georgians
to vote on account of their race or
color in violation of section 2
of the voting rights act
several studies show that georgia
experienced record voter turnout and
participation rates
in the 2020 election cycle approximately
two-thirds of eligible voters in the
state cast a ballot
in the november election just over the
national
average this is cause for celebration
but then in march of 2021 georgia's
legislature passed sb 202
many of that law's provisions make it
harder for people to vote
the complaint alleges that the state
enacted those restrictions
with the purpose of denying or abridging
the right to vote on account
of race or color in a few moments
assistant attorney general clark
will talk in more detail about this case
united states versus georgia
i want to thank the staff of the civil
rights division's voting section for
their hard work on this
matter and for their everyday efforts to
protect
americans voting rights the critical
nature of their work
is the reason we are doubling the
sections enforcement staff
this lawsuit is the first of many steps
we are taking to ensure that
all eligible voters can cast a vote
that all lawful votes are counted and
that every
voter has access to accurate information
the civil rights division continues to
analyze other state laws that have been
passed and we are following the progress
of legislative proposals under
consideration in additional states
where we believe the civil rights of
americans have been violated
we will not hesitate to act
we will use all existing provisions of
the voting rights act the national voter
registration act
the help america vote act the americans
with disabilities act
and the uniformed and overseas citizens
absentee voting act
to ensure that we protect every
qualified american
seeking to participate in our democracy
under the supervision of the associate
attorney general the civil rights
division
is also taking proactive measures to
help states
understand federal law and best
practices
we are in the process of developing
guidance to help ensure that
post-election audits comply with federal
law
and we are working in guidance with
respect to early voting
and voting by mail and because the
upcoming redistricting cycle may be the
first since 1960 to proceed without the
key pre-clearance provision
of the voting rights act we will publish
new guidance
to make clear the voting protections
that apply to all jurisdictions
as they redraw their electoral maps
these include maps used for
congressional districts
state legislatures county commissions
city councils and more
pursuant to president biden's executive
order we are also working to ensure
access to voter registration for
eligible individuals
in federal custody and will assist other
federal
agencies in expanding voter registration
opportunities
as permitted by law finally
as i noted two weeks ago we are seeing a
dramatic increase in menacing
and violent threats ranging from the
highest
administrators to violent volunteer
poll workers to address this
effort to undermine our electoral
process
today the deputy attorney general will
issue a directive to all
federal prosecutors and the fbi which
will highlight the prevalence of these
threats
and instruct them to prioritize
investigating these threats
today we will also launch a task force
including personnel from the criminal
division
the civil rights division the national
security division and the fbi
to focus on these threats we
will promptly prosecute any violations
of federal law
we are using every method at our
disposal and our enforcement efforts
but that is not enough we urge congress
to act to provide the department with
important authorities it needs to
protect the voting rights
of every american eight
years ago today the supreme court issued
the decision
in shelby county versus holder
prior to that decision the justice
department had an
invaluable tool it could use to protect
voters from discrimination
section 5 of the voting rights act
under that section any change with
respect to voting in a covered
jurisdiction could not be enforced
unless the jurisdiction first proved to
the justice department
or to the united states district court
for the district of columbia
that the proposed change did not deny or
abridge
the right to vote on account of race
color
or membership in a language minority
group
using that tool the department promoted
prevented over 175 proposed election
laws across
georgia from being implemented because
they failed
the statutory test if georgia had
still been covered by section 5 it is
likely that
sp 202 would never have taken effect
we urge congress to restore this
invaluable tool
i will now turn the podium over to
kristen clark
who will tell you more about our filing
in united states
versus georgia
thank you attorney general garland two
weeks ago
you made clear that the department will
spare no
effort to protect voting rights in this
country
as you and i have discussed on many
occasions the civil rights division
stands on the front lines of this work
while it is the honor of a lifetime to
lead the division charged with upholding
the nation's civil rights laws it is
also a great
responsibility today that responsibility
requires that i announce the division
has found it necessary
to file suit against the state of
georgia
the civil rights division did not arrive
at this decision lightly
it's our job to follow the facts and the
law
and in this case our careful assessment
of the facts
and the law demonstrates that georgia's
recent voting rights law violates
section two of the voting rights act i
want to thank the voting section for
their tremendous efforts on this
complaint and everything that
they do and i want to express my
appreciation to the acting u s
attorney and staff of the northern
district of georgia for their
partnership
and support our complaint today alleges
that
several provisions of sb 202 were passed
with a discriminatory
purpose in violation of the voting
rights act
the georgia legislature passed sb 202
through a rushed process that departed
from normal practice
and procedure the version of the bill
that passed the state senate on march
8th was three
pages long days later the bill ballooned
into over 90 pages in the house
the house held less than two hours of
floor debate
on the newly inflated sv 202
before governor kemp signed it into law
the same day
these legislative actions occurred at a
time when the black population in
georgia continues to steadily increase
and after a historic election that saw
record voter turnout across the state
particularly for absentee voting which
black voters are now
more likely to use than white voters
our complaint challenges several
provisions of sb
202 on the grounds that they were
adopted with the intent
to deny or abridge black citizens
equal access to the political process
the provisions we are challenging reduce
access to absentee voting at
each step of the process pushing more
black voters to in-person voting where
they will be more likely than white
voters to confront
long lines sb 202 then
imposes additional obstacles to casting
an
in-person ballot like all of the
provisions in sb 202 the changes to
absentee voting were not made in a
vacuum
these changes come immediately after
successful absentee voting in the 2020
election cycle
especially among black voters
sb 202 seeks to halt and reverse
this progress first the law prohibits
election officials from distributing
unsolicited applications for absentee
ballots
as they did during 2020.
the law irrationally shortens both the
period during which voters can request
absentee ballots and the period during
which election officials can mail them
out
to voters in the 2020 election cycle
a voter in georgia could request an
absentee ballot up to 180 days before an
election
and up until the friday before election
day
under sb 202 the state moved the
deadline for requesting an absentee
ballot by a week
a critical period quote a critical time
period close to election day
where data shows that black voters are
more likely
than white voters to request an absentee
ballot
sb 202 imposes substantial fines on
third-party organizations
churches and advocacy groups that send
follow-up
absentee ballot applications and
requires
new and unnecessarily stringent
identification requirements to obtain an
absentee ballot
we are also challenging a provision of
sb 202 that places restrictions on
drop boxes and would limit access and
ease of voter
participation in the 2020 elections and
the 2021 runoff election the georgia
state election board allowed
voters to drop off absentee ballots and
drop boxes
this method of voting was widely
deployed in the metro atlanta area
where the largest black voting age
population in georgia resides
during the 2020 election cycle the four
most populous counties in the metro
atlanta area
provided over 100 drop box locations for
voters
under the bill that number is expected
to drop to roughly
20. the drafters of sb 202 did not stop
their efforts at making absentee voting
more difficult
historically minority voters in georgia
have been disproportionately more
likely to wait in long lines to vote in
person on election day
given those long and protracted wait
times civic
groups including churches have at times
provided food
and water to voters in line to make
their weight more comfortable sb 202
bans
the distribution of food and drinks to
voters in line
as we allege in our complaint this
needless ban
was passed with unlawful discriminatory
intent
finally our complaint challenges a
provision of sb
202 that reduces the likelihood that out
of precinct provisional ballots will be
counted
it's well documented that communities of
color change
residences more frequently than other
populations
and because of this greater residential
mobility
and polling site closures and
consolidations
black voters are more likely to end up
at the wrong precinct on election day
sb 202 reduces the chances of eligible
voters have the ballot counted
section two of the voting rights act one
of our nation's bedrock
civil rights statutes prohibits the
enforcement of
any voting practice or procedure that
has the purpose of denying
or abridging the vote on account of race
color or membership in a language
minority group
as we allege today sb 202
violates this federal law
the attorney general has made clear that
the justice department will not
stand idly by in the face of unlawful
attempts
to restrict access to the ballot today's
filing demonstrates the commitment to
this charge
the civil rights division stands ready
to protect the constitutionally
guaranteed voting rights
of americans in georgia and wherever
else those rights may be threatened in
our country
thank you kristen clarke um we have time
for a few questions
attorney general um you referred to the
number of states
uh legislators legislatures that have
passed
new voting laws in the last couple of
months um can you say whether those
some of those laws that have passed in
mostly republican states
uh is under those under review by the
department
with the with the view to perhaps
challenging them in the same way you're
doing this and then secondly
um i think the deputy attorney general
issued a memo to the field on
the issue of threats can you say whether
any any idea of how many threats are
under investigation
or is this an effort to sort of get
ahead of the 2022
election cycle uh with regard to threats
to election officials
on the first question um it is as i said
we're looking
at laws that were passed before as well
as the ones that have been
recently passed and as they are being
passed
and we'll make the same kind of judgment
that we made with respect to this one
the voting rights section has a process
for evaluating them
and when the process is completed if we
decide to make
a filing we'll do so and of course we'll
let you know
with respect to the second question we
are concerned very much
both about deterring threats
and about prosecuting past threats if
they violate the law
as to the numbers i think i'll give the
deputy attorney general a chance
to talk a little bit more
thank you and thank you for the question
evan um look
citizens who protect our right to vote
are fundamentally protecting our
democracy and so we have to protect them
and that's why i issued the directive
the attorney general spoke of
a few moments ago which does two things
fundamentally it launches a task force
in the department to ensure that we are
bringing the full resources of the
department to protect
election officials whether they're
appointed whether they're elected
whether they're volunteers regardless of
party and also what it does is
prioritizes and sends a very clear
message to the field to every federal
prosecutor and the fbi
that we need to prioritize the
investigation the identification
it asks them to engage with state and
local officials we have to identify
these threats
prioritize their investigation and
prioritize those prosecutions and hold
these individuals accountable
who are threatening election officials
one of the reasons for this task force
and centralizing reporting which is what
this directive also does
is to make sure we fully understand the
real scope
of these threats to election officials
and fundamentally
to the right to now to the atlanta vote
constitution hi um there are already
seven pending lawsuits in georgia
against
sb 202. how is this federal lawsuit
different what do you think the doj
brings to the table with all these other
actions already pending
well for myself i'll just say you know
we've said in the
um complaint you'll see it's quite
detailed says exactly the provisions
um that we're filing with respect to
with respect to the
relationship to the other lawsuits i'm
going to let the assistant attorney
general for civil rights answer
the civil rights division carefully
follows the facts and the law and here
that's what we did we looked carefully
at the
georgia law and determined that there's
an important federal interest
to protect here and that's ensuring that
eligible voters across the state of
georgia
enjoy equal access to the ballot
regardless of race
um we will continue to do just that we
will continue to analyze
other laws that may be passed across the
country we'll follow the facts and the
law we'll look at these laws carefully
and where we determine
that there may be a potential violation
of the voting rights act
or another federal civil rights law that
the justice department is tasked with
enforcing
we will act thank you
yeah just a couple of questions one on
on the voting rights
lawsuit what prompted on the threats
issue
just following evan's question what
prompted you specifically
to make the direction that you made
today what
what about the threats moved you to
to take that action
mr attorney general you met with news
organizations recently to discuss the
seizure
records is there anything more that you
can do in terms of
legislation at congress to
to push that issue forward so on the
first question i want to give
credit to the news media there were a
number of articles that collected
all the threats and discussed them
putting them together in a way that i
have to say frankly i had not
seen before and when i saw that
significant number collected in that way
and i realized quite clearly how
important this was now we had been going
after these threats as they occurred
sporadically and individually but
given the collection um on and the
number
it became apparent we need to have a
more focused uh uh
and prioritized uh result and that
that's why the
deputy attorney general uh developed the
task forces that
we announced today uh and that's why i
asked her to issue the
memorandum field which she did today uh
on your second question
um um uh just
generally um what we're planning to do
with respect to the subpoenas
to reporters going forward
is that we will not seek information
by compulsory process from reporters who
are doing their jobs and we will not
seek information about reporters records
from third parties
under the same circumstances uh your
durability question is a very good one
so
my intention is to get this out as a
memorandum
quickly to the field so that everyone is
clear about our position
that will then be followed by
regulations
which will make it more durable more
durable
but you are right and suggesting the
only way to really make it permanently
durable is through legislation and i
personally will support
uh working with congress to develop a
legislation that would make
uh protections um for obtaining
the press's records part of the
legislation all right thanks everybody